TAKAKO AIKAWA: So my
name is Takako Aikawa.
I'm a senior
lecturer in Japanese.
As the leader of the
Japanese language program,
I am shaping the direction
or future direction
of the Japanese language
program, and at the same time,
improving the existing
language curriculum.
So the high-level overview of
the Japanese language program
at MIT is, so we
have three tiers--
beginning, intermediate,
and advanced courses.
And each layer aims to
develop four language skills--
reading, writing,
speaking, and listening.
And our main focus,
however, is to improve
so-called communicative
skills, be able to communicate
with native speakers.
My first encounter
with language teaching
was when I was a
graduate student,
I applied for a
teaching assistantship
for Japanese teaching.
I originally was trained
as a theoretical linguist,
so I didn't know anything
about language teaching.
But when I first
taught Japanese,
I found a great gem
in language teaching.
And since then, I'm very
passionate about language
teaching.